What was the revolution,
I mean did in the 19 sixties,
um,
it was a sense of,
it was,
it was really a questioning of how had
this country
with this commitment to democratic
values justified,
you know,
a series of prejudices and tolerances
including,
um,
treatments of,
of women as less than fully human women
couldn't have a bank account.
Women couldn't have a credit card,
you see,
you don't remember that.
And I remember teaching at Harvard,
there were no women on the faculty.
Um,
and that all changed.
That changed relationships between men
and women.
And the issue I was talking about
before,
which was for a woman to feel that what
I know or what I believe or what I think
or what I feel or what I want is
legitimate.
And it's not the only thing,
but it has legitimacy of its own,
was huge rather than seeing it as
selfish.
Now that of course if you've been at you
introduce want or desire,
you introduce sexuality and you know,
in the old sort of framework,
women were seen as not wanting.
Sex is not sexual beings.
It's not having desires and thoughts of
their own quota.
Funny Authority on this,
which is Freud who said that the so
called intellectual inferiority of women
was due to their needing to suppress
their sexuality.
Because if you couldn't think about all
aspects of yourself,
you had to start restricting how that
you could think at all.
And also I would say having to distance
yourself from your body because your
body was seen as somehow bad or wrong.
You lost touch with your experience and
then it was very easy for women to not
know what they knew through experience
and to be open to all kinds of.